[Music]
in copyright claim Jews Oh
oh my god stop it
ooh YouTube submitted by flavortown
welcome to flavortown I've got Fieri its
diners drive-ins and dives
I'm also a fifty year old guy that looks
like a dweeb did he say that you thought
slavery tell ya he's stuck in 2001
Yeltsin in the last part it looks like
well like you see blowing smashmouth or
something like a Smash Mouth member all
grown up yeah I hate the guy Bella
already all grown up like you don't like
his entertaining sours his restaurants
are trashed his oh so you don't like his
taste
I don't like it's tasting food and
anything but are they more novelty based
food like so for example Sacramento he
opened up a place called Tex wasabi
Texas sushi and it was terrible so it is
like barbecue ribs with [ __ ] soy
sauce or something yeah it goes down it
close down and meet it was so [ __ ]
bad dude like that yeah cuz I was high I
was like yo Guy Fieri opened up I love
this area sounds stupid though Texas
sushi it was he looks like he wears puka
shells
yeah but he keeps him under his but
enough with the flames not good man oh
yeah
hot topics number one customer yeah um a
lawsuit over cheese has emphasized the
fact that flavor cannot be copyrighted
is it most
oh no flavor can't be copyrighted so if
I make my own spa broth and someone
steals my recipe I can't sue them I
wonder if they would have to do I come
down to the ingredients you know but
that's I mean that's kind of what it is
too though right do you all see food
trends pop up dude like it's hard to
protect food yeah how do you do it right
yeah we get jacked all the time yeah
like literally we started doing handmade
different like flavored like cones right
so a lot of people just buy their stuff
yeah and I kid you not
like another business I did it for like
a month and it the same cones popped up
at that other business and they already
stole the other line recipes to it's
like do you just wait for me to do
something and then you just take it yeah
[ __ ] you know I mean but you can't do
anything about the cab it just is what
it is I haven't see the same thing
clothing will make something in another
company will come out with something
very very similar you can you can't lose
your family do anything because they're
just using their logo and their branding
but it's like the same you could tell
that's the same thing
yeah like forever21 does the exact same
thing like anything that you see popping
out right now you'll see it forever 21 a
week later oh my god yeah just worst
quality and a quarter of the price maybe
10% the price and then it devalues the
whole brand and like oh my god did
anyone else see how there was this Gucci
shirt that started popping up in the
past few weeks everyone had the same
exact Gucci shirt and it was a ripoff
Gucci shirt that some place was selling
for like $50 so like because nobody
wants me $50 on a damn t-shirt so they
felt like it was still a little nuts but
they know I warned it wasn't Gucci yeah
I saw everybody wearing that for a hot
minute and it values the whole brand you
know it's gone oh yeah so that's why
just buy gold rarely yeah
just [ __ ] look like a [ __ ] pimp
[ __ ] what's mr. t I see both of both
tees I love ice-t he's a cotton now over
20 years
ya seen people that run do you see gold
rope badass rope
I just want big one big one what's the
show that I seize on this the police
show monitors he's like always
interrogating people for some reason
yeah he's been playing the same role for
20 years click that check is a stripper
but she looks good for like 60 in the
show or for real life in real life a
blonde up she's like a Vegas late and I
she's not 60 I don't know how hot she is
that doesn't sound off yeah cuz he's
pretty old to it yeah yeah you look like
somebody he would date like 30 years
under though yeah true because I don't
like old [ __ ] hey this whole story
here it revolves around is cheese spread
with she's friends that already sounds
know this takes place in
Netherlands so there was a lot they were
gonna see another land
yeah you know that's how the name was
created because I think there was like
Holland and then they're like and then
there's another lands and they just
became anyway yeah motherland damn I
thought be just mispronounced Neverland
ah yeah so there was a Dutch company
that called that bought this recipe from
a small grocery store in the Netherlands
and and and so this Dutch company called
this cheese a particular name and then
almost right away there were all these
other imitations that popped up on the
market and then so there was this other
company I started selling that cheese
and so the first Dutch company brought a
lawsuit against that second company
claiming copyright infringement and so
they were trying to force the cease
production and then that case went all
the way through the Dutch courts until
referred to the EU stop court and then
it finally ruled that quote the taste of
a food product is not eligible for
copyright protection because copyright
refers to the expression of an
intellectual idea not the methodology or
the recipe itself which might be cover
lifetime if those were allowed in the
food world
oh so also recipes can't be patent or
copyright yeah yeah they can't
dependence okay yeah
well because copyright is different
because it's for creative expression or
inventions maybe that's why people have
their secret recipes yeah I mean because
if somebody gets it anybody could go
cool yeah like Coca Cola's thing is in a
vault that's true I mean what have you
ever tasted any other color brand that
he's like oh cool now cooked is the best
like sarsaparilla or some [ __ ] that's
why when they did the Pepsi challenge
people actually prefer Pepsi like when
they blind test unless they're really
into Coke but even even people that work
for Coke that did the Pepsi challenge or
whatever they like Pepsi better but then
the branding is so good for Coke
that people like Coke yeah the branding
for Coke is good
those polar bears it's that polar bear
coke season good but see like every time
they do a new marketing scheme is so
smart like remember they enjoy enjoy a
thing and people were just like he free
promo all over Instagram like enjoy a
coke with Tiffany like yeah everywhere
do you look for your name you look for
your own name right I didn't even look
for that because they never have mine
they never have rose in any of those
name keychain things magnets networks
rolling up I always look than not once
not even close most restaurants to like
I feel like you don't have an excuse to
make really shitty food anymore like a
lot yes a lot of basic cooking [ __ ] like
you could make a make like for example
when I go to like a barbecue joint right
and they have a [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
pound of like mac and cheese and it just
tastes like [ __ ] it's like dude you can
look up a recipe on youtube right now
that's really good that's a basic mac
and cheese recipe you could do for your
restaurant why the [ __ ] you keep making
this garbage are you just make any sense
[ __ ] do you know excuse pin yeah I don't
understand it dude it's like okay while
I make this [ __ ] burner it's like well
there's a recipe right there on your
phone just do that sometimes I feel like
restaurants forget to add ingredients
cuz I'm like there's absolutely no salt
or something uh or definitely just film
people just can't taste food or
something I don't know what's going on
they have cooks that don't like to cook
that's cooking for just money mmm I
think that's what it is to like they're
just there cuz they're it's a job yeah
well the whole tasting that's what
happened here when they were like it's
impossible to say that it has the exact
same flavor from the same person from
the same person saying like okay this
tastes exactly like this because it's
all like subjective and they're saying
you can't really like measure that
that's why you can't copyright I still
go to this joint near Silver Lake and
they had like when I thought was like
some of the best mac and cheese ever and
the one time they made it whoever
whoever did it they basically the the
bechamel that they made was too thin and
it was just like soupy and watery and I
haven't gone back there since because I
got the mac and cheese I always get it
right and I turned it back and I go I
was like oh this is like super thin and
it's like cold too like
she was like I've never seen anybody
returning mac and cheese before and I
was like cool what the [ __ ] does have to
do with this being [ __ ] turn my [ __ ]
back she goes well nobody's ever
returned one before I hate when they've
done that you're like well I'm the first
I saw was like are you gonna take it bad
and she goes well nobody's ever returned
one but she just took it I was like why
is she giving you a tit I don't know cuz
I uh I went there at least once a week
so it was like dude I've never returned
this before so clearly this is bad she's
getting I haven't been back since were
you so in shock that you didn't you know
dispute that like Iceman cheese all the
time I just owe him take it back and I
she took it back and after that like
[ __ ] I pay for it I just never came back
yeah I mean that's like the ultimate
[ __ ] you I didn't even finish your food
yeah I'm paying for the whole thing
goodbye yeah I was like what the [ __ ] is
the argument here say so nobody ever
returned it back I understand a little
[ __ ] we take it back dude like what the
dog called yeah macaroni is it supposed
to be al dente it depends so if you have
like southern mac and cheese they tended
like they'll cook it all the way through
yeah and then they'll cook it again in
the oven so it's more mushy and soft I
actually like my macaroni and cheese not
to be authentic because I wanted to
absorb everything I mean so I like it a
little more cooked all the way through
and if you're doing like in a potluck
sense it's hard to cook it al dente -
exactly so some people do which I think
a majority of like recipes they tell you
to make it out then - like pasta yeah I
don't even know how to eat mac and
cheese the right way yeah I don't even
use macaroni for my mac and cheese I use
other possibly do you use the little
corkscrew ones oh my god that's the
sauce it's so good it's so good you ever
had rosemary and mac and cheese
[ __ ] you I use a cavatappi
that's like my favorite noodle to you
yeah cavatappi is also like a twirly one
she's bombers oh the pasta yeah did you
already be done and make your own
handmade pasta I always do I like you
actually fine if I make if I eat pasta
normally now I just make it a the
machine yeah she got me a pasta making
me it's just a rolling it out so the
dough's a hardest part that's easy
making making pastas not that just
another piece like 15 minutes or
something it's pretty fast if you do it
in a food processor it's pretty quick if
you do it by hand like people say it's
better by
I can't tell the [ __ ] difference it's
the same to me but it's cheaper so if
you want pasta at home and you don't
have it it's literally egg flour water
and most likely you have that in your
house never mind
we got the water covered yeah but pasta
super easy me can you tell the
difference if you use tap water or like
purified water I haven't done like a
side by side tap water tastes like [ __ ]
I could taste it in restaurants too like
I can always taste tap water in
restaurants it's name I could I can't
tell if I I haven't checked it with that
but I always use I have the the purified
water tap next to the things I always
use that anyway so I'm wondering if tap
water in baked goods you could tell the
difference probably because there's like
minerals and stuff an actual filter
water because I also do that when I made
ramen like I didn't use the tap water I
use the the purified water you got it if
you're making broth yeah you have the
good [ __ ] dude mm-hmm
[Music]